avec danièle obono député la france
insoumise de la 17ème circonscription de
paris c'est notre invité politique ce
soir bonsoir danièle obono merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france 43e
jour de mobilisation et personnes qui
lâche à part évidemment l'âge pivot 1
voulu par la cfdt mais sur le reste on
semble vraiment déterminé à tenir ses
positions quelle est votre réaction
mais parce que en même temps la
situation appelle à ce que la
mobilisation reste forte en vérité
l'ensemble du projet de loi et de la
stratégie du gouvernement est restée
intacte et le gouvernement monsieur
edouard philippe a essayé de faire un
espèce de coup de bonneteau en faisant
croire qu'ils reculaient temporairement
sur l'âge pivot mais le texte transmis
au conseil d'état contient sous la forme
de plusieurs articles plusieurs mentions
de l'ajdp équilibre ce qui est
exactement la même chose
et de toute façon ce qu'il a annoncé ne
concernerait qu'une partie de des
générations concernées par les retraites
bref
en vérité le sens même et ce qui est
inscrit dans le texte de loi a même et
confirme le l'opposition nécessaires à
cette réforme avec par exemple des
incitations à développer la
capitalisation épargne retraite
et puis on sait en vérité il va y avoir
par le système par répartition des
retraites plus faibles et les gens vont
être obligés à travailler plus longtemps
pour pouvoir avoir des eaux trading donc
voilà le système à points
c'est un système de régression sociale
et voilà pourquoi est ce que je pense
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
étaient encore mobilisés aujourd'hui et
surtout une majorité de la population
soutient la mobilisation et ne croit pas
à toute la propagande gouvernementale
qu'on entend depuis des mois et qui
montrent surtout en fait leur
incompétence parce qu'ils n'arrivent
même pas
même à expliquer comment on va prendre
en compte les secteurs précaire comment
on va savoir
là bas le niveau de retraite ans à tout
ça il s'embrouille
parce qu'en fait c'est un espèce de jeu
de dupes et au final on faisait la cge
il manque véritablement peut-être une
étude d'impact ce souhait dans les
mauges en vacances et face à orléans ce
que les français enfin je sais pas ce
qu'ils pensent d'ailleurs c'est le son
des sondages qui le disent ils ne sont
pas contraints une réforme pour la
majorité d'entre eux en tout cas mais ne
savent pas là en l'occurrence à quelle
sauce ils vont être mangés c'est
vraiment ce qui manque aujourd'hui selon
vo mais pas seulement parce que tout le
monde va être pour une réforme pour
améliorer les choses si on vous dit est
ce que vous voulez un système universel
alors l'université paris viii vincennes
l'universel c'est des droits en plus
c'est non nous sommes pour
l'universalité donc si vous présentez
les choses comme ça ça va être plus
juste plus équitable bien sûr mais c'est
un mensonge flagrant parce que déjà le
système il a été réformé à plusieurs
reprises au cours des dernières les donc
ce n'est pas vrai que on aura un système
qui serait le même qu'en 45 ce n'est pas
vrai nous nous pensons qu'il a été
réformé au cours des dernières années de
manière négative parce que c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles le niveau de
tension a baissé globalement mais il ya
eu des réformes avant et qui vont dans
le même sens et le gouvernement actuel
s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans le sens de ces
réformes
on explique qu'il va y avoir un déficit
probable prévisionnel mais pourquoi
parce que justement les politiques qui
sont menées notamment par exemple la
réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
qui font partie de ceux qui cotisent le
plus en nombre et aussi en vente aux
âmes et va amener effectivement à un
terme à une réduction dans ce sont les
politiques même de réduction de la masse
salariale d'exonérations de cotisations
sociale qui crée le déficit dont 100
n'explique pas et puis je pense que ce
qu'a révélé aussi le mouvement des idées
jaune depuis un an c'est que même si
notre système permet d'avoir le taux de
pauvreté des seniors le plus le plus
faible en europe donc le système par
répartition permet ça quand même malgré
les attaques qu'il a subies et bien
justement à cause d'eux des réformes
précédentes on a des situations où on a
passé toute sa vie à travailler sont
très durs avec dp modeste on a pu être
au chômage et on se retrouve ensuite à
la retraite avec des revenus sous le
seuil de pauvreté donc c'est une
situation un dollar donc tout le monde
voudrait réformer ça aujourd'hui déclaré
dans le meilleur sort on s'en sort pas
on a le sentiment quand même même si
vous vous réveillez on l'a dit 60% des
français soutiennent ce mouvement on a
quand même aussi le sentiment d'une
france divisée il ya beaucoup de gens
ont beaucoup parisien notamment qu'il
souffre de cette grève par les
commerçants la sncf qui perd pas loin du
milliard moody son patron aujourd'hui
alors le point ça va vous faire sourire
évidemment c'est un journal forcément
engagée à droite comment la cgt ruine la
france fait la une du point
cette semaine il n'empêche on s'en sort
comment pour pour arrêter ça vous allez
me dire le retrait du projet vous savez
que le gouvernement ne va pas le faire a
priori en tout cas échéant la santé
c'est la seule solution excusez moi
d'abord je rappelais je rappelle que la
grève
écoute d'abord à ceux et celles qui la
font vous savez pas où on est on est
d'abord franchement aujourd'hui il ya
des gens qui vont risque de recevoir des
feuilles de paye avec 000 euros c'est
souvent des secteurs c'est la majorité
de ces personnes qui ont des peines
modeste quoi qu'on en dise est ce qu'on
dise sur les soi-disant pris vie
privilégié de la sncf etc
donc voilà ça 40 jours c'est historique
dans l'histoire des mouvements sociaux
mais c'est d'abord dur pour ces
personnes et puis effectivement la grève
bloquent en partie l'économie c'est pour
ça que ça fait un rapport de force
d'ailleurs les soi-disant concession la
halle espèce d'enfumage qu'à essayer de
faire monsieur philippe c'est aussi
parce qu'il ya un rapport de force et
une pression et c'est parce qu'il ya eu
7 ce rapport de force une pression
on a fini par comprendre qu'il y avait
la capitalisation derrière et blackrock
et que c'est ça aussi qui fait qu' on se
rend compte et je pense une majorité de
gens se rendent compte aujourd'hui qu'il
ya un loup dans cette réforme et que ce
n'est pas tenable donc oui le point de
départ c'est pas un point d'arrivée
c'est un point de départ pour qu'on
discute de comment on réformes pour
aller vers le mieux le mieux vivre pour
tous et toutes
comment on rend notre système solidaire
encore plus égalitaire le début de ces
discussions sera possible quand le
gouvernement on va retirer ses vrais
gens et puis ça mc ça s'appelle les
mouvements sociaux ça s'appelle la
démocratie c'est du rapport de force
certains ont dit jusqu'au bout nous ne
cèderons pas et ont fini par sceller
parce que il ya aussi quand même le
sentiment en tout cas jusqu'à présent
chez des responsables politiques de se
rendre compte on peut pas gouverner
contre son peuple
on ne peut pas que jean luc mélenchon
chedjou souhaite une motion de censure
qui a été dans la foulée rejetée
d'ailleurs par le ps et par le pcf vous
tombé de l'arbre comme jean luc
mélenchon l'a dit vous aussi qu'ils
aient rejeté cette motion de censure
c'est un projet étonnant de la part de
nos camarades du parti communiste et
peut-être aussi leur stratégie
d'alliance à venir qu'il est qu'il est
contraint mais je pense que c'est
surtout une erreur de leur part a eu de
la part du parti socialiste c'est un
peux malheureusement pas très surprenant
parce qu'en vérité ils sont d'accord
avec le système de retraite par prison
qui le fonds propres et la présidente du
groupe socialiste a indiqué s'est
exprimé dans plusieurs médias en disant
il ne ferait pas comme ça mais en fait
voilà la retraite à points ça leur va
bien quand même
et donc oui je pense que l'or lors leur
vision politique
ils ont besoin dans des 60 ans le départ
à 60 ans quand même un oui oui mais
autour des corps à ce niveau là mais
nous on a un problème on a proposé un
contre projet mais au delà je pense que
c'est c'est y compris tactiquement c'est
une erreur c'est en ce moment même où la
pression menés par la grève est à son
maximum que nous devrions nous en tant
que parlementaire là où nous sommes
aidés à ce mouvement en expliquant qu'
effectivement nous sommes opposés à ceux
à ce texte et donc on censure le
gouvernement mais ça ça fait partie des
procédures parlementaires donc les
raisons invoquées sont ne tiennent pas
en vérité on en est on vous l'avait dit
à plus 40 jours de grève c'est
historique et on accepterait non
parlementaires de faire comme d'habitude
et d'accepter et de commencer à débattre
d'un texte alors qu'on est en désaccord
et alors que fondamentalement c'est
aussi un projet de société qu'on remet
en cause le le le la retraite par
capitalisation ces deux logiques de dire
en fait chacun pour soi alors que ce qui
marche et ce qui est des ce qui a aidé
notre système depuis 45 c'est le tous
ensemble et on partage des oui c'est ça
aussi qu'on devrait expliquer dans cette
motion de censure
nous sommes en espérant que nos
collègues vont revenir à la raison et se
rendre compte que c'est justement le
moment où il faudrait mettre le maximum
de pression sur le gouvernement avant
que le texte soit débattu parce qu'on
sera entraîné là dans la logique et la
mécanique institutionnelle de faire des
amendements et du coup ce sera d'une
certaine manière leur avoir concédé la
légitimité de porter ce débat alors qu'
il ne devrait pas avoir d autres thèmes
sur lesquels je voulais vous faire
réagir ce ne serait pas le temps
d'aborder tous les thèmes que le dossier
était dévié dans son lit ciel emmanuel
macron qui alors je ne sais pas on va
voir votre interprétation est ce que
selon vous il a fait un pas vers les
victimes emmanuel macron une forme de
mea culpa
non ces déclarations ces derniers jours
plus de déontologie de la part de la
police
crise de conscience vous y croyez
je pense qu'il ya un mélange
d'irresponsabilité de mensonges et de
lâcheté dans ce que j'ai entendu pas
simplement d' emmanuel macron mais
demande du gouvernement
moi je les ai pas entendus cité une
seule fois le nom de zineb redouane le
nom de steve canico le nom de cédric
chou via le nom de ibrahim bah je ne les
ai pas entendu une seule fois a annoncé
qu'ils se rendraient auprès des familles
et qui présenteraient leurs condoléances
aux familles et qui s'excuseraient et
assumerait la responsabilité politique
de ce qui a conduit à la mort de ces
personnes ces quelques noms mais je
pourrais parler avoir amélioré la
déontologie c'est pas un des buts quand
même des voeux écoutez encore une fois
nous depuis plus d'un an ça fait plus
d'un an que ça dure qu'on a on vit dans
ce pays un tournant extrêmement grave où
après la débâcle benalla le gouvernement
s'est défaussé sur la hiérarchie
policière
et puis face à la contestation sociale
ils ont choisi et ils ont assumé et ils
ont assumé encore jusqu'à dernièrement
une stratégie d'organisation du désordre
parce que pour moi ce n'est pas du
maintien de l'ordre de réprimer
d'essayer de faire taire la contestation
sociale par la violence et c'est pour ça
que ensuite vous avez des éléments les
plus extrêmes
parce que heureusement on n'est pas au
point où c'est toute la police mais il
ya un cadre général ya une doctrine et
quand monsieur l'allemand le préfet de
police assument de ne pas être dans le
même camp qu'un citoyen assume y compris
de d
signé c'est les manifestants et
manifestantes comme des ennemis il prend
parti
il prend pas le parti de l'ordre
républicain il prend le parti d'un ordre
policiers qui défend un régime qui
défend une coterie qui défend la macro
ni et ça c'est inadmissible et surtout
jusqu'à présent vous avez quand même des
monts de ce gouvernement qu'il nie
l'existence même de violences policières
vous avez monsieur macro qui elle qui a
le fasse et c'est là ma chronique
caractérisée qui explique qu' il y à des
violences par exemple contrôler contre
les journalistes mais que c'est surtout
le fait des manifestants alors que
quelques jours encore il ya un camp
quelques jours un de vos confrères se
trouvait arrêtés et amenés dans un
commissariat lille et relâché 24 heures
plus tard sans aucune charge
alors que plusieurs de vos confrères ont
fait des signalements auprès de l'igpn
est que jusqu'à présent il n'y a eu
aucune procédure il ya un cynisme qui
est absolument que je trouve moi
absolument écoeurant et encore une fois
nous l'avons demandé nous leur demandons
la démission de monsieur l'allemand le
préfet qui et qui dirige aujourd'hui
cette stratégie et de monsieur castaner
qui s'est montré totalement incapable on
est quand même et je finis là dessus
mais oui il ya aujourd'hui un une
organisation corporatiste de la police
qui depuis plusieurs mois menace des
avocats me lasse des journalistes menace
des partis politiques d'opposition et
aujourd'hui on vient ni même à menacer
d'une certaine manière le ministère de
l'intérieur voilà ce qu'ils ont créés
ils ont créé ce monstre là et donc non
je ne je ne me laisserai pas enfumer par
les discours ambivalent
je crois qui a pour les personnes qui
sont mortes pour osi même redouane style
canico ibrahim ba pour dernière ces
personnes dernière chevalier de pros des
excuses il est gavé des missions pour
répondre à ça un sondage aujourd'hui qui
a attiré mon attention la cote de
confiance malgré tout ça des manuels
macron alors elle est pas brillant de
ses 32 %
de français qui lui font confiance mais
tout de même en hausse de 2 points en
janvier
et parmi cette hausse il progresse
notamment ce n'est peut-être est étonné
j'ai pas si vous l'avez vu auprès de vos
électeurs en tout cas les électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon +6 comment vous vous
expliquer ça à son âge qui depuis des
mois nous explique que il progresse il
progresse en restant à 70% à plus de 70
500 ses intérieurs de grâce aux deux
électeurs du premier tour
oui mais font selon elle est lente et
écoutez franchement voilà c'est vraiment
un sketch permanent cette histoire de
sondage sur la l'impopularité parce qu
on présente ça en plus c'est la
popularité à 30% si dans son élan cluzet
stendhal et la popularité à plus de 70 %
et 10
il descend jamais en dessous de d'un
certain niveau comme si c'était non
franchement je pense que au delà de ça
monsieur macron aujourd'hui symbolise le
président des riches au service de la
finance et de et de blackrock je pense
que depuis plus d'un an avec depuis la
mobilisation sur des filets jaunes et
aujourd'hui tous les secteurs salariés
vous avez des avocats vous avez des
danseurs et danseuses de l'opéra de
paris vous allez enfin voila il a réussi
à rallier contre sa politique et sa
personne une majorité de français et
françaises et il dirige et il gouverne
pas pour l'intérêt général et pour 20%
de la population sur lesquels il espère
pouvoir être grâce auquel il espère être
au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec voilà le pen potel
cissé
d'annulation de l'extrême droite ces
thématiques c'est absolument déplorable
je pense que une grande partie de la
population l'a compris aujourd'hui et
que le retrait de cette réforme de cette
mauvaise réforme participerait à
affaiblir ce pouvoir ma chronique qui
est aujourd'hui en roue libre et qui
doit être stoppée maintenant par la
grève et en 2022 par l'élection
merci danièle obono député la france
insoumise la dix septième
circonscription de paris